[Musique]
non non non non non non non ces filles à
que je ne peux pas je peux pas croire
que votre flûte elle est magique le cep
on trouve ça dans tous les bazars là
c'est pas possible tu plaisantes et mais
non elle est machine à danser pape
hausse mais pourquoi écouter c'est vrai
qu'elle a un pouvoir fin extraordinaire
non non est ce que c'est bien elle elle
a le pouvoir d'arrêter n'importe qui et
dans n'importe quel mouvement on
l'arrête semblables alors quelqu'un il
pas au foot depuis bob c'est directement
il se rappelle plus de rien
j'ai du mal
on n'est pas leader et elle pourrait
arrêter même un abruti comme ça vous
même un abruti comme toi là mais je veux
voir quelque chose dit dans et alors on
dit pas bonjour à tout le monde quand on
dit bonjour
ça y est c'est pas qu il en colère plus
bête que d'habitude vous pouvez pas de
remettre en route d'un jeune et voilà
et t'as rien senti tu sens rien du tout
mais non mais non senti atteint rien
senti dans toi
dida vous pourrez pas me leur fils
j'aimerais que vous leur fils acier
encore une image
oui tous leurs feux le mal mais pas la
fin mais pas lui pas lui et kings of
comedy lab
c'est pas vrai regarde on dirait une
vitrine de magasin ni dans l'orient
n'est pas du foyer au fait c'est partir
[Musique]
on ne fait pas du tout énervé vous voyez
pas nous l'a prêté on voudrait faire
court a dit luc chatel
non il n'est pas question que ces mots
doivent faire dans la loge puis les a
dévoilés tuiles et dans les poitrines et
les voilà
voilà c'est dommage parce que j'aurais
aimé vous me
mettez là
c'est dommage
ces deux régions on aurait pu rigoler si
vous voulez on va rigoler quand même
parce que je
regarde le savez vous où se trouve votre
jolie partenaire ennemis à la bâtisse
vallée où les deux hommes appartenaient
à prix
elle est par là pourquoi ce que j'ai une
surprise pour elle ah bah oui mais vous
pouvez la trouver la balle
ça marche
[Musique]
[Rires]
au
mas sereni vos partenaires nous ont dit
que c'était votre anniversaire
aujourd'hui le nombre assister je chéris
de la part de serait digne en loa nom
aura si quelques fleurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]